when it comes to red carpets whose
outfit are we always eager to see
Zendaya's this isn't just a coincidence
her stylist law roach has paid a
significant role in her success the
dynamic duo have been collaborating
since Zendaya was 14 and she's been
serving looks ever since roach
attributes her stunning fashion journey
to a clever strategy of getting Zendaya
noticed he explains nobody wanted to
dress him when she wasn't known so I
would put her in things that other
people had already worn this earned her
exposure in the celebrity weeklies who
wore better columns and soon enough
people started to know her name fashion
helped her transition from a Disney star
to an actress with global box office
appeal we wholeheartedly agree Zendaya's
fashion choices have made her an iconic
presence on every red carpet especially
events like the Met Gala it has become a
tradition for us to eagerly anticipate
her incredible looks